On an ordinary day in 1991, a young man known
by the initials J.S. went on a hike with four
of his friends on the wooded outskirts of
their small town.
Everything seemed perfectly normal until J.S.
began to feel a strange sense of familiarity,
like he had been in this spot before.
He couldn’t shake this weird feeling, but
thought nothing more of it.
Little did he know that this was a sign of
deadly things to come.
Several hours after first experiencing that
sense of deja vu, J.S. was found by the side
of the road, covered in cuts and scratches,
with his friends nowhere to be found.
This is the story of SCP - 939, an unforgettable
monster that you’ll never remember.
There was no way for J.S. to know that the
unsettling feeling he felt and the horrors
that followed it were the result of an experiment
conducted by the SCP Foundation, an experiment
with deadly unforeseen consequences.
J.S. and his friends were exposed to a substance
known only as AMN-C227 as part of a series
of tests performed by the SCP Foundation intended
to determine the effectiveness of this substance
as a deliberate amnestic.
Dealing with as many mysterious, secret creatures
and objects as they do, the SCP Foundation
has long needed a way to tamper with the memories
of those exposed to the foundation’s various
prisoners and test subjects, and, when the
foundation discovered AMN-C227, it seemed
like it might be perfect for this purpose.
So where did AMN-C227 come from?
Over a year before the incident with J.S.
and his friends, the SCP Foundation captured
SCP-939.
SCP-939 is a species of endothermic predators
that live and hunt in packs.
They are designated Keter class, and regarded
as highly dangerous and hostile to human life.
Native to caves, they have no eyes, translucent
red skin, and stand at an average of 2.2 meters
tall, with an average weight of 250 kg.
They have four limbs, each ending in three-fingered
claws and a fourth opposable digit resembling
a thumb.
In addition to their sharp claws, their mouths
are filled with red, fang-like teeth that
reach up to 6 cm in length.
In place of their absent eyes, they have light-sensitive
spots running along their backs, which are
covered in spines believed to detect changes
in air pressure and flow.
In addition to their many other terrifying
attributes, the internal anatomy of SCP-939
poses a biological mystery.
These creatures have no circulatory system
and no digestive tract.
That’s right, in spite of being predators
seemingly acting on a need to feed, they have
no stomach.
Instead, when they eat their food builds up
in their respiratory system until its presence
inhibits function, and then it is regurgitated.
In spite of being a creature that should not,
under any logical conditions, be able to live,
SCP-939 continues to persist, and is even
capable of giving birth to live young after
a gestation period of 12 months.
The SCP Foundation was able to study a litter
of these young that were born in captivity
in September of 1992, though the creatures
remain just as much of a scientific mystery
as they were upon first discovery.
Everything about them seems to defy the logic
of the natural world - which, to be fair,
is really nothing new for the Foundation.
The respiratory system of SCP-939 was found
to exhale small traces of an airborne amnestic
substance, given the name AMN-C227.
This compound blocks the formation of memories
for the duration of exposure to it, plus a
thirty minute period following the exposure,
give or take a few minutes.
It is colorless, odorless, tasteless, and
completely undetectable in the bloodstream
after only 60 minutes.
AMN-C227 was approved for use as a Class C
Amnestic by the SCP Foundation in 1990 following
some initial tests.
However, after one particular incident involving
a young man and his friends, the official
use of AMN-C227 was suspended.
J.S. and three of his four friends were previously
given a dose of AMN-C227, though the details
of why they were given the amnestic have since
been stricken from the record.
Several months after being exposed to AMN-C227,
J.S. and friends went out on their ill-fated
hiking trip.
While hiking, J.S. was suddenly overcome with
a sense of deja vu.
When he mentioned it to his friends, three
of them agreed that they felt it too.
One of the group, another young man - who
had not been exposed to AMN-C227 - was uncomfortable
and decided to go home.
J.S. and the remaining three members of the
group made the choice to stay in the woods
and try to determine what was triggering the
unusual feeling of familiarity.
As they got closer and closer to a large cave
near the hiking trail, the sense of having
been there before grew stronger and stronger.
Armed with only one flashlight and a foolish
curiosity, the four went inside the cave.
They made their way deeper and deeper into
the darkness, not knowing why they felt this
way or what they might find inside.
None of the group could explain just what
felt so familiar, only that the further they
made their way into the cave, the more pronounced
the feeling became.
It was getting late, and they knew they should
have been afraid to venture so deep into a
cave with only one light source and no knowledge
of what lay inside, but still they pressed
on.
One of the group remarked that they should
turn back, but the others refused to listen.
They wanted to know what they were getting
close to, what was drawing them deeper and
deeper into the cave.
Unfortunately for them, they would get their
answer.
In the heart of the cave was a pack of SCP-939,
waiting patiently for their prey to wander
into their domain.
There are no witnesses to account for what
exactly happened to J.S. and his companions,
but we can reasonably piece the events together
from what happened after.
Once the friends reached the heart of the
cave, the creatures were on them in seconds,
raking them with their sharp claws and biting
with their fangs.
SCP-939 are larger and stronger than most
people, so it was probably not much of a fight.
However, while his friends were being devoured,
J.S. was somehow able to scramble out of the
cave and make his way into the woods in search
of help.
Under the influence of the AMN-C227 that had
built up in the cave from the presence of
the pack of SCP-939, J.S. lost a large portion
of his memory of the event.
He found himself on the side of the highway
late at night, seriously injured and his clothes
ripped.
An officer found him there, and asked him
to stay still and remain calm until an ambulance
could arrive.
J.S. was still in a panic and attempted to
run away from the officer, begging to be released
so that he could get away.
He babbled incoherently about the color red,
screaming over and over again about the “red,”
though when prompted he could not explain
what the “red” he was screaming about
referred to.
His friends were not with him.
Just as the officer managed to calm J.S.,
the ambulance arrived.
Its flashing red lights sent him into another
frenzy, and he attempted to escape custody,
claiming that the red lights were “going
to get” him.
The official police report described J.S.
as perhaps being under the influence of a
powerful hallucinogen.
That he was just having a “bad trip,”
but the SCP foundation knew better.
The foundation conducted an interview with
J.S. about his experience, and determined
that SCP-939 was certainly involved.
As part of their cover-up effort, they strongly
implicated J.S. in the disappearance and death
of his friends.
He was convicted of manslaughter, though the
bodies of his friends were never found.
It is rumored that the SCP Foundation hired
him on a prison work release program, and
that he now works as a member of the janitorial
staff at one of the Foundation’s facilities.
This incident led to the suspension of the
use of AMN-C227, as it revealed some vital
and disturbing information about the compound’s
side effects.
After exposure to AMN-C227, a person who found
themselves exposed to it again would experience
a sense of familiarity, and feel compelled
to investigate the source of this feeling.
Essentially, anyone treated with AMN-C227
and not made aware of the existence - and
danger - of SCP-939 would become a perfect
victim, primed to be attracted to dens of
SCP-939.
It is likely that this side effect is not
a coincidence, but rather a deliberate hunting
tactic designed to attract prey that had somehow
managed to escape.
With no memory of their attack at the hands
of SCP-939, this previous intended prey would
find themselves drawn to the same den or even
a new one, not knowing that they were walking
back into near certain death.
While the SCP foundation suspended the use
of AMN-C227 as a Class C amnestic, they did
recruit a team of SCP field operatives to
take advantage of this side effect.
This team of operatives was deliberately administered
a dose of AMN-C227 and briefed on its effects,
as well as the dangers of following the feeling
of deja vu should it surface in the field.
These infected officers were essentially used
as bloodhounds, relying on any sense of unusual
familiarity to sniff out new dens of SCP-939
so that they could be captured and contained
by the foundation.
As far as we know, this operation is still
ongoing today.
However, now that the foundation has a sufficient
number of specimens to study, additional dens
of SCP-939 that are discovered are ordered
to be immediately destroyed.
As for the SCP-939 still in captivity?
They are contained in environmentally regulated
and negatively pressurized cells with walls
of reinforced concrete.
The doors to the cells are air-tight to prevent
the leakage of any AMN-C227, and any personnel
that interact with one of the creatures is
required to wear Level C Hazmat gear to avoid
exposure, and follow decontamination procedures
upon exiting the cell.
All SCP-939 have subdermal tracking devices
implanted to find them in the event of escape.
Only one SCP-939 has given birth in the time
that the creatures have been in captivity,
and only one of the litter survived.
Strangely, SCP-939 young look indistinguishable
from human infants, and change their physical
appearance at some yet unknown point as they
age.
If any more offspring are produced, they will
immediately be separated from the parent and
studied.
The SCP foundation has redacted all information
about the location of these creatures or the
incident involving J.S., refusing to reveal
where their natural habitat is.
All that we know is that they are found in
caves in the woods outside of a small town.
It could be any town, even yours.
Sp if you’re ever out hiking, and are struck
with a sudden feeling of deja vu?
Don’t investigate, don’t get curious,
just go home.
It might just save your life.